The joe rogan experience.
So what is the corporation
about the corporations?
The story of the Cuban American organized
crime organization that began in the
mid 1960s and existed all the
way to the end of the century.
And it was led by this mobster
named Jose Miguel battle,
who was kind of a legendary figure in
Cuban American circles because he was a
hero from the Bay of Pigs invasion,
the a and the attempt to
reclaim Cuba take back Cuba,
the invasion, 1961 which was a
disaster for everyone involved,
battle wound up in prison along
with the rest of the brigade.
And when he got out and came back to the
u s he was determined to get Castro and
take back Cuba.
So he set up this criminal thing
and it was based on a one racket,
primarily Bolita the number,
the lottery,
the illegal lottery for the lottery
was illegal. It was illegal,
and it was controlled by organized crime.
And it was a huge moneymaker,
big moneymaker for the mob. Going back
to the 1920s everyone bets the number,
a little old ladies, but the
number of priests, cops, you know,
you can bet a nickel,
you can bet a dime.
You can bet $10,000 hugely profitable
for whoever controls and organizes it.
Well the Cubans controlled and organized
it on the eastern coast of the United
States from New Jersey and New
York all the way down to Miami.
And the guy who controlled it was battle
and he became legendary based on that.
They controlled the whole number system.
Cause I know there's a lot of
Italians that were, well they went,
they went to the Mafia.
One of the first things battle did battle
had been a cop of vice cop in Havana
in the 1950s during the,
for the turnover. Yeah,
during the era when the mob of Joey
was talking about Havana Nocturne.
That's what that book was about.
The era of the mob in a van in the
fifties Meyer Lansky Santo traffic content
and how they controlled that until Castro
came along and spoiled the party and
the revolution happened and they
got chased out of their battle.
Had been a vice cop in Havana during
those years and he knew all those uh,
high ranking mobsters.
And in fact he was a bag man who delivered
money from the Skimm at the casinos
in Havana to the presidential palace.
So battle knew how the world went
round and he made those connections.
And when he finally gets to the U
S and wants to start his own thing,
first thing he does is go to
Santo traffic. Content says,
can you make the proper
introductions from me?
Profit content introduces him to fat Tony
Salerno in New York City who controls
the numbers are accurate for all
five families. And battle says, look,
things are changing in Cuba
over the next couple of decades.
You're going to have tens of thousands,
if not hundreds of thousands of Cubans
coming to live in the United States.
They all bet the number. That's a huge
market. If you let me take over this
thing and organize it,
you will get a piece of,
you will get your piece of everything.
And the Mafia said yes.
And so the Cubans took over
and they control everything.
I mean in New York City in
the seventies and eighties,
there were probably 200 to 300 Belita
spots where you could go bet the number.
That's what the Cubans called the
Bolita, a little ball. And uh,
so they controlled it and they took care
of the mafia and everybody was got fat
and happy, uh, for awhile until it turned
bad and they started killing each other.
Now when Joey,
when you heard about this book,
this is something that you
were very intimately involved
in when you were a kid.
Very,
you know,
I come on your show and I'll tell you
there's a hundred stories I could tell you
there's a thousand I can.
And when he told,
when I read the thesis for this book,
I just knew,
I just fucking know.
You know,
I grew up in numbers when I went to
Catholic school on of, and I'm like,
I came home on Fridays and
Saturdays at the age of Eight,
I was sent to different locations
in the city, the Bronx, Brooklyn,
and I would make $50 going to run errands,
run the numbers.
They'll tell this guy the first
number of the day is to, you know,
so I grew up in it.
I grew up in a house where the bookie
would call my mother by three o'clock and
go,
what's the numbers for the day?
And My mother would give him a fucking
laundry list, you know? And uh,
it's very interesting in this book,
He also covers
the mysticism of the number.
So if I'm at your house and your daughter
walks in with a hockey shirt and a
number is 13, I'll look
at you and go, Joe,
give me a number from zero to
nine five and I pick up the phone.
I bet five 13.
If I look out my window and
the cop car is five Oh six,
I put $5 on five oh six.
If I have a dream about an eagle,
when I go down to the Bolita spot, there's
books that they sell books or dreams.
And I take that book and I look up Eagle.
And if eagles number eight,
I pay eight 13. It's, you know,
you were mentioning a couple months
ago that your grandmother took numbers.
Grandmother was Sicilian.
Sicilian people have the same,
uh, every day they live. Today's the day.
Today's the day Joe Rogan. Yup.
I, the day I'm hitting the number,
I'm not getting you. She talked about
that dream. That dream would. Again,
we're going back on immigrant mentality,
those street numbers today. If God wants,
if God is real well,
he says it's true.
My number's gonna to come
out to that one is my ship.
Got to come in that work. You work
a plain Jane Dream. You wrote,
you were a blue collar person and I'm
the way home every day. By three 30,
you put the number and that's it.
That's what you do and to believe in.
That's something I can
relieve. Yeah. Numerology.
And with Cubans, uh, it was very
mystical.
It was tied into a dreams and belief.
The idea was you bet the number and
you try to make your dreams come true.
That's literally what you're doing. You're
trying to make your dreams come true.
And the bullied the guys, the bully
terros the ones who control it there,
the dream makers, they're the
guys who are making it possible.
For your dreams to come true.
So they had tremendous stature in the
Munich minimum,
every dream Saba.
So you work the tjs Jose Battle
and you're an independent bookie.
Your job is to sit at,
at bring the lounge and Westlink 10th to
three drinking and all day long people
come in and go, Joe gimme, five 17 $3,
give me three Oh three one doll at three
o'clock, three 30 a number comes up.
If that number wins, if I can give
you 500 you get 3000 from battle,
you give me 2,500 so you make 500
off the top. And then I tip. Yet,
the thing that battled did
was he didn't take 10 points.
He let you run your independent
action unless you called it in to him.
You know, it's very, you're
watched the movie, uh, uh,
what smooth Mickey Rourke and the
these people, you're the dragon.
That fucking movie, great
movie. When he says, you know,
for years the Chinese will bring it into
heroin and they were sending it to the
Italians, you know, a $50,000 investment.
It can make you $500,000 Chinese weren't
saying that like they weren't seeing
that. Why? Because they didn't
have, they couldn't bring it out.
They couldn't sell it. Black people and
Spanish people bitch slap them to that,
so the same thing
happened with Bolita fat.
Tony Salerno knew that he had a
big thing coming with the Cubans.
The Cubans want to put a
better with Cubans. Yeah,
they understand the Italians. They want
to put a bet on where the Italians,
Puerto Ricans, they want to put a
better than with a Puerto Rican.
It's not a big thing.
That was with the numbers.
It was that there was a community thing.
It's a community that actually would
talk about the numbers and be like the
lottery is some sort of a government
funded gang and it seems like it's got a
lot of red tape and official
and there's no wiggle room.
The numbers seem to be
closer to like the community,
especially with Latinos, especially
with [inaudible]. It was the,
in some ways the core of the community,
the number of spots where
everybody would hang out.
You'd go to hear the
neighborhood Lobola in like the,
the gossip and the streets. He'd go there
and here in the neighborhood, guys up.
Uh, yeah, it was an end. It
was never meant to be violent.
Back in Cuba. Belita was
not violent. It was illegal,
but it wasn't violent and it turned very
violent than you in the United States
to corporation became so profitable.
I mean,
we're talking about millions
of dollars on a monthly basis,
billions of dollars over course
of the life of this organization.
Billions of dollars more than they could.
The artist thing they had was what to
do with the money. I mean, they, they,
they would literally strap money to people
to as money couriers to try to get it
out of the country to get it into
getting into offshore bank accounts and
launder the money.
They had more money than they know
it was a license to print money,
which hugely profitable.
That's what made it violence.
Then you started having
gangsters vying for territory,
territorial disputes, greed, greed
took over and it got very ugly.
And there was this, this
between Cubans, between Cubans,
between the Cubans and the Italians.
See,
this guy battle was very
charismatic leader, uh,
with some great leadership qualities.
He'd been a hero in the Bay of Pigs
invasion. He saved some guys lives. Um,
when I first heard that
story, I didn't, I said,
I got to verify that maybe this is
just the story I told about himself to
burnish his legend.
So I found the guys that he
saved and I found the guys,
two brothers who went with him to
save that the guys that he saved.
And I went to Cuba,
to the Bay of pigs,
to the exact location where he saved
these guys to verify this story.
And it was absolutely true. He, in
a, an act of incredible heroism.
He saved the life of a number
of his platoon members.
And so that was his reputation. From
then on, he was revered in the community.
He was a hero and people
defended him even, even when it,
it turned ugly and he became a ruthless
boss who was killing people left and
right. He had his defenders because of
his legend as a hero in the community.
And so, um, the power that
he had. But he also had this,
uh,
Joey and I were talking about this
tube and tab this Latinos have this,
everybody has it,
but Cubans have it a desire for revenge.
This guy,
you know,
the Bay of Pigs invasion was an attempt
that revenge to get revenge against
Castro.
And they were humiliated by that process.
And a lot of the guys from that generation
had an unfinished agenda for revenge.
So if you wrong this guy battle in
any way, he was going to get you,
even if it took years and
years of calculation. I mean,
there's stories in the book about this
one guy who killed his brother named
Pilou.
He took,
it took nine years and 12 attempts
before they finally killed this guy,
Paul Lula. They shot him in his
hospital. He was in the hospital.
They shot him how to assassinate dressed
up as a male nurse and go into the
hospital and shoot him between the eyes
because there had been so many failed
attempts, they weren't going to fail this
time. And that's in battle to 12 years.
I mean, took nine years. His awesome.
No, never caught him. No, no way.
Bank disappeared.
I believe the assassin got killed later
cause he was talking about it having
done it and so battle had him
killed. Wow. Yeah. So the,
the revenge motive,
the revenge motive, um,
kind of trove battle off the deep end.
And uh,
somewhere along the line he
broke bad, so to speak. I mean,
I don't know if he was ever
good and had to break bad,
but he started doing internal killings.
It really had nothing to do
about business. They were
all about revenge. Well,
this is a theme that happens a lot
with organized crime people. Right?
It's like they just get a taste of
killing people and it becomes easier and
easier. And then they, that was the
thing about murder machine, right?
About Roy Demeo, right?
Yeah. You just can't,
was killing people and
nothing to it after awhile.
And that's another book you gave me.
Yeah.
I was reading all those books on the road.
Okay.